we need help
[Music]
our targets name is Brixton he's a ghost
we're gonna need the best trackers in
the business blue cops I'm what you call
a nice cold can of whoop-ass courier la
men always gets his guy crushing it in
this film from this trailer from what
we've seen one thing I know about the
Fast and Furious franchise is every film
people say they get better and better
and better so is this the best one how
is this sort of similar to the franchise
and how is it separating itself well
it's similar to the franchise in terms
of we made sure that we wanted to make
sure that there's still had the DNA of
Fast & Furious movies and the DNA of
Fast and Furious movies what I mean by
that is it's a thing that fans have been
really enjoyed over the years being
action set-pieces
defying gravity around every corner
where you're like wait is that possible
what the best period it's cool I'm
holding the hell I can really do that
right now you scare wouldn't be the word
I would pay you a compliment
but yeah so it was important that we
paid homage to the spirit of Fast and
Furious but it was also it was also
important that we had our own identity
in our own tapestry and our own kind of
mosaic and wanted to make sure that we
created a movie that was fun and badass
and cool and and all these things for
the fans but also a little bit of a
pivot and the pivot was yes the stakes
of the world are among us and in these
fast and fierce movies you've got to
save the world right it's my fourth time
saving we're pretty good at it
thank you very much I'm kind of good
because I can control a lot of the
script that's why I'm good producer so
I'm like I will save the oil again but
also making sure that we had this really
cool chemistry that was like a biting
chemistry between two individuals who
audiences have grown to really like over
the years in these movies and myself and
Jason Statham and also had this kind of
vintage throwback feel of movies like
lethal weapon and Midnight Run and 48
hours movies like that from the 80s that
were classic action movies but then you
come in with a great director like David
Leitch who of course directed John wick
atomic blond Deadpool to
and he has a very stylistic approach to
filmmaking in action sequences so we
worked our asses off for this I always
believe in a little bit of luck and we
launched that first trailer people were
like this is bananas we love this
give me more we launched the second
trailer and it was like holy [ __ ] guys
you see the rock hold a helicopter in
midair and all this other craziness and
and working on another trailer now and
then in the movie of course which
eventually you will see and everybody
will see we we deliver on all the things
that were they were the goal to
accomplish and then there's some nice
surprise your sister took something from
me that grave was in position possible
like because I'm such a theater girl
those those women for me when I was
growing up what would like totally my
icons in the theater so it's quite weird
to be doing action movies and playing
their daughter but yeah it was wonderful
she's so fun and when you go from from
the crown where it's very emotional and
there's not a lot of physicality to it
is there a similarity between doing that
and doing this is there some sort of
core similarity or is it feel completely
different and I know as an actress you
tent you people want to stretch
themselves and do things I've never done
before
does it was there a common ground or
does it feel like something completely
different I I guess you you apply the
same process I really wanted to make
like a proper psychological journey I
did loads of research on mi6 and like
criminal criminal families in London and
like you know did this whole backstory
and everything and so I almost tried to
make the character like have
vulnerabilities and an emotional journey
as much as anything it just felt kind of
that felt really important to try and
bring that to it so that it wasn't just
I sort of I mean I don't know any women
that are just solely just like you know
either super emotional and animal or
what are you strong in it but also like
you know impenetrable like sometimes I
women in action movies who were like so
invincible and sort of like cold in a
way and that also I kind of wanted to
try and like do all the things in in the
character so that it's yeah I don't know
I don't know if I've done it it was a
co2 well I've heard I've heard that you
more than do it that you're iconic
absolutely I was just told that can't
wait to see crazy one reason why these
films resonate is because it balances
really well the action with Hart
families the word you heard a lot during
Fast and Furious movies so can you speak
a little bit to that and sort of the
heart of the film what are the heart of
love about this film you know it's it's
a movie where it really it's just
exploring the the obvious sort of like
big bang big explosion big creations but
at the same time in sort of the
consistent conversation of how the most
important thing at the end of the day is
family and I think that we can all
relate to that we're all out there
trying to do our thing but the most
important key thing to success is having
value to what you have and paying homage
to towards that so I think that this
franchise specifically in this expansion
goes into so nicely because you have the
dynamic between Vanessa and Shaw which
you they're obviously brother and sister
and then you'll see a little bit more
about home Marin in it to that kind of
expands that world and then you see DJ's
character go into Hawaii and sort of
expand into that world and sort of like
we will do I think the consistent
conversations we would do anything for
family families first and foremost and I
thought that was beautiful and
in its own capacity every character does
the same throughout the film so I I
think people are gonna be really excited
and just enjoy the movie it's a fun
movie as well it comes up with a lot of
comedy they have incredible comedic
timing so and that's why people wanted
there to be a you know it's been up so
you said you've been watching this since
you were a kid yes do you remember the
first one was it the first movie that
you saw and did you ever think I'll be
in that movie never you an actress at
the time I was I I mean no I was
probably like I won't say because
they'll be so obsessed it's really yeah
doing about that baby
I was younger than your daughter no
kidding but I was really young with the
first movie came out and I do remember
seeing Michelle Rodriguez and thinking
wow she's so cool because there's this
love story obviously happening but she's
also an identity of her own and I
thought that you know at the time it was
very rare to find characters especially
when it came to Latina characters that
kind of had their independent self made
strength to its own so I really was
excited when they reached out to me and
like we would really want you to be in
the movie I could not believe it and I'm
excited and hopefully I can become that
for other girls and feel inspired that
they could be one day here cuz it's
totally doable and can happen you know
what happened to me I was coming from a
different country I was in Mexico like
it was completely an idea that could
never really live in my head like a
reality and here we are so hopefully
there's a little girl watching somewhere
that will be in fast 25 people getting
better buckle up Zeppelin
whoa hey see the look on his face you
have no idea how long I've been waiting
to do that so we need to know the haka
ritual because I know you perform it in
the film it was one of the best parts of
this trailer was the haka ritual that I
think it was supposed to be in Samoa so
sort of just talk to me a little bit
about that first of all you know thank
you for saying that and it's a great
opportunity for me to correct I'm not
saying that correct you but there's so
many people who have said oh he's doing
the haka in the movie but actuality it's
a Seva tau
now the Seva tau in Samoan is in a way
you could say it's the Samoan version if
you will of the haka but they are two
really distinct experiences but still
the same mana in the same spirit so
thank you for bringing that up it can
get loud like we there's a moment on set
where that you AG we actually used it in
the trailer at that time our director
nobody knew that I was gonna say it and
it's a moment where I'm calling on my
ancestors and my brothers and I say Zoe
uh and it's from here it's kind of got a
ruling from your gut and that's when all
my brothers come up and we start to see
the Tao so and it's very emotional by
the way just like with the haka by the
way or any of these rituals I think that
come from cultures where it is done out
of Pride and it's done out of survival
and in this moment of war and in this
moment there's a preamble in the movie
that I do and I speak in Psalm Owen I'm
calling on my ancestors strength and I'm
saying that this ground that you stand
on has been nourished with my ancestors
blood and today it's gonna be nourished
with yours do you feel like this is the
most personal movie you've ever done and
for that reason just 100% 100% the most
personal movie that I've ever done it
you know and that's the I think the fun
irony of a movie like this where it's
Hobbs and Shawn it's a and it's a it's a
big fun tentpole summer movie but for
the first time on the big screen in a
tentpole global movie the Samoan culture
is being exposed
and and showcased and it's such a cool
thing I'm half black and half Samoan so
to be able to showcase one of my
cultures on screen so incredibly
meaningful to me and for the whole movie
without giving it away for the movie to
descend upon this little island in the
South Pacific where the fate of the
world lies and it's alive it's just
really beautiful and very personal in so
speaking of rituals because that is a
ritual do you have you've done these
films they're so high adrenaline if we
were to see you in your trailer like
moments before you go on set you know
ritual or something you do to get
yourself jacked up before doing these
like high like for moments like that
just for well for for the firth of
energy scenes Oh
usually I turn up my music really loud
so there's two parts of it I tournament
music really loud and I'll find
something that whatever's gonna move me
whatever it might be hip-hop song it
might be orchestral song I don't know
like whatever can move me and then then
I usually shut it all down and get
really really quiet and I have my chat
with the universe and just say thank you
for this opportunity and please grant me
the strength and and grandly the ability
to connect and here we go mama where's
all our guns I can't read up on very
noble mrs. Hobbes no in serious trouble
yes understatement that's good old
school
playing Jason's sister and there has to
be a bonding process where you're you
feel like family in a sense you're
grinning I feel like well it was like
times when we were like crap who had to
cram into this McLaren so you very money
got Dewayne who's massive it's like
Jason Exley who's driving like me in the
middle there was one time actually so
like we were like super like press
Stoppers like how I was busted because
to be peeing
Jason was driving and I was having to
shoot right I panicked and as I was like
who do you think whatever like is that I
was like he went like that why he was
driving its maximum knows who's driving
he's like you don't meant to do that
you're always like you don't cross like
with like you don't cross to the fire
towards some rails I'm like really bad
but you seem to because you have a
twinkle in your eye when you talk about
shooting God I know although late they
don't you don't anyone's that I won in
the movies you just pretending like no
electric rounds I would go I would make
the sound yeah nobody there was one time
interest he's like I just adored there's
one time when he's doing his sequence
than me and him were fighting a bit and
he kept going to movie yeah you making
sounds of the fight while you're doing
is that oh my god I didn't realize the
whole time was I've been reading all
don't to do that so this is a new
character we don't know a lot about your
character yes
so tell me what you can and is this
possible to setting up a whole new
universe like the Hobson Shasha universe
is a something to use maybe okay I can't
say that maybe you know I think that if
the fans love it it all depends on them
and I am just so grateful to be part of
this it's just really exciting you know
I grew up watching the passive viewers
happy ah so now being part of also for
me it was very special to create this
character of a Latina in this franchise
because hey I do know that a big
following of the this franchise is
Latino it's looked in a community so
it's incredible for me to be part of it
because I feel like I I'm contributing
to prolong more opportunity for us but
yeah but
and she's a she's a total badass she
knows what she wants she's driven she's
independent she's strong I love that
she's a character who is not a damsel in
distress in any capacity and by the way
I will say Vanessa Kirby is absolutely
incredible in this film she's amazing
and she will be so inspiring for future
other films to create equally badass
characters or her because she's not
trying to be tough she is just who she
is
who's a real woman with as we can relate
real emotional issues and problems and
but not trying to overplay that and at
the same time she's a complete badass so
Madame Emma is the version of that as
well
but in the darker sense she is you'll
see throughout what she what she gives
back to the boys and how she's
completely kneaded by them how they
completely need her to kind of continue
their mission so she's really cool and I
mean I'm excited for people to see her
in action the only white who survived us
working together like a team let's do
this she winning this massive franchise
and you're a newbie was there a ritual
did Dewayne sort of was there an
initiation did anything or was it just
like guns blazing day one were just
getting one day one day one started with
I was most in all of David just because
having to learn like to fight at that
level with him and like Greg this better
remember yes done so many amazing action
I know and it's all select the nicest
man on earth
really bad if like you're not doing it
that well he's like oh sorry I think I
forgot to breathe during that but um the
first shot was I was doing a play at the
time and so I was knackered I just just
finished off a six-month run
and it was a Sunday morning and I had
the only shot in the movie where it's
all one take of a other stunt so like
slice up recklessly but and I was in
full-blown my mi6 gear like goggles
helmet massive like weapons everywhere
like really go and I had to take those
guys out and then do a flip roll and end
up on my knees like that and pull at the
camera it was like my first day and I
play Wow awful oh so Barris and like
really hot and flossing very sweaty and
I had to do it again and again and again
and again over to my flipped I flipped
like a crab I didn't look cool it was
just everyone was sort of like flustered
no one knew each other it was like yeah
so I mean you kind of just answered it
but what was the thing that you got to
do in this film that you've never gotten
to do before as an actress I mean I know
you did
Mission Impossible and there's a lot of
action there but this seems like the
auntie is just that I know yeah it's
yeah it's like a it's like a David
Leitch maybe really in that sense it's
like it's just spin-off of you know we
see something it's saying for love but
it's very much like his amazing sort of
yeah expression I guess um in that sense
it was like for me the fights or the
thing are just so excited to do just
because I think also like challenging
yourself something I'm really not
naturally like I was the worst at sports
though you know always lost the running
race never wanted to do it always like
crap at sports generally and so the idea
of like I don't know try to convince
people that I'm like a stronger fighter
is there's anyone you know yeah I was
like a big challenge that's amazing to
me because having watched you do action
before you sell it so in quite no one's
done admission you yes I just so I'm so
nervous it's gonna let Tom Cruise down I
just somehow managed to put like what so
doing did I read that when you saw this
character on paper you said she was the
fiercest character you would ever read
before what does a fast and furious
script look like because there's so much
action and what did what sort of does it
look like on the page well it changed
all the time so yeah
was kind of evolving all the time
depending on lots of different factors I
mean like the first time you really see
her she she beats up and I just for me
it felt like if I can really take care
of this of this character I feel like
it's so important and whatever genre it
is you know obviously it's like
extremely different the things I've done
before and I just felt like it was
really crucial to to create a character
and a woman that that was luckily equal
you know and it's and it's unfortunately
it's been rare in the past to see that
there's a lot of like male heavy
franchises and a lot of male heavy
action it just felt really crucial to
really build a character in this view
for me I felt like little girls could
walk out the cinema I feel like I can be
her and she's as strong as him so just
to close things out you talk about
saving the world four times everybody
wants to know if you're going into space
ever are you are Hobson's shy ever going
into outer space what is the final
frontier will you save the universe what
is beyond eventually the final frontier
for Hobbes and Shaw I think you know
when you think about growth which is
what I wanted to do with the passage
would well just the the universe itself
you wanted to build it out so you build
out you start with obscene saw and if
we're thinking about building out from
Hobbes and Shaw you save the world then
what's next the universe and then the
galaxy right then it's like come and
watch Hobbes no shop oh sure yes he dies
just saying we won't tell anybody
[Music]